[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the sky new
city Studio
the chancellor tells Sky News he'll do
whatever it takes to bring down
inflation even if it means a recession
there's nothing automatic about bringing
down inflation it is a big task but we
must deliver it and we will
no sign of inflation putting off
Shoppers though as retail sales come in
stronger than expected
the former Tesco chairman John Allen
says he may Sue The Guardian newspaper
for its reporting of allegations about
his personal conduct
and how augmented reality and artificial
intelligence are being brought together
to help people with hearing loss
thank you
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well the chancellor
has told Sky News the government will do
whatever it takes to bring down
inflation even if that means a recession
Jeremy Hunt said he'd fully support the
bank of England raising interest rates
again with analysts now expecting rates
to Peak at five and a half percent he's
been speaking with our economics editor
Ed Conway
we will halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt it was the first of Richie
sunac's five pledgers as prime minister
halving inflation now the chancellor
says he's happy for Britain to go
through more economic pain if that's
what it takes to do it it comes after
higher than expected inflation data
prompted markets to lift their interest
rate expectations to 5.5 percent
something that could push the UK into a
slump are you comfortable with the bank
of England doing whatever it takes to
bring down inflation even if that
potentially would precipitate that
recession that you've almost just
avoided yes because in the end the
inflation is a source of instability we
have to support the bank of England in
the difficult decisions that they take
and what I would say Ed is that when the
Prime Minister announced that it was his
objective to halve inflation in January
there were some people who who derided
that they said well it's automatic
inflation is going to come down in any
anyhow there's nothing automatic about
bringing down inflation it is a big task
but we must deliver it and we will even
if it means precipitating a recession
well um we will deliver this task and we
will make sure that the government plays
its part the bank of England plays its
part but it is not a trade-off between
tackling inflation and recession in the
end the only path to sustainable growth
is to bring down inflation one of the
main reasons Liz trust and quasi
quattang were booted out of office last
year was that after the mini budget
there was Financial chaos and interest
rate expectations went up to six percent
really sunak and Jeremy Hunt's main
claim was that they were going to
stabilize the economy but now with
interest rate expectations back up to
five and a half percent even that is
under question
the prime minister's five pledgers were
supposed to be easy the problem is that
solving number one halving inflation
might mean failing number two growing
the economy at Conway Sky News
analysis by PWC suggests a total
household debt in the UK has exceeded
two trillion pounds for the first time a
research by the consumer lender fluoro
suggests that's only going to rise
joining me now's fleuris chief executive
Nick Harding Nick welcome to you I mean
one of the things that struck me is
you're seeing a lot of Demand right now
for consolidation loans yeah good
morning and nice to see you again um we
are seeing demand for consolidation
loans but indeed we're seeing demand
across all categories
um if you compare figures with this time
last year the loans being dispersed in
the market are approximately similar to
this time last year however the number
of loan requests has gone up by about 22
and in particular we're seeing that from
some challenging uh parts of the market
you know lower income households uh
households where there's often one
person in the household where they're
more susceptible to the price Rises that
we've been seeing 22 rise in loan
requests so I mean that's pretty
stunning it really is um you know
there's an element of it that we think
is is slightly more positive and an
element that we unfortunately think is
is negative an element of it is that
customers are going into the market
to find credit and they're seeing the
credit is more expensive and so
fundamentally they're saying to
themselves we're not going to make this
life purchase at this moment in time
which we think is ultimately you know a
responsible decision to make
um but at the same time we say lots of
customers come to the market because
they need credit and that's more
concerning because you know we're seeing
those households having some distress
and we think that you know in many cases
more credit is probably not a good thing
what do you think is driving that is it
higher mortgage rates higher higher
rents we think a combination of all of
the above Energy prices have certainly
been a factor in terms of of uh you know
household challenge is but we're seeing
you know by the end of 2024 5.1 million
mortgage holders will have their fixed
rate period come to an end and there's
going to be a big jump up in terms of
costs for those households
um so there's households coming to terms
with that is is a really you know
challenging situation a manual for a
loans both directly and Via Partners
what's the sort of typical size of a
loan you're being approached for these
days yeah so we offer loans to Prime and
near Prime customers this is uh you know
the same customers that Banks would
often lend to
um we the average size of a loan that we
disburse is about eight thousand pounds
um and and these customers our customers
that typically have gone to a bank and
are quite often badly served by a bank
so you know they'll see a higher APR on
the loan that the bank than the bank
originally had shown and they'll say to
themselves you know I don't feel
comfortable with this I prefer to go and
uh you know look around the market they
will then do so and they'll see a better
offer from a company like fleura like
mine
um and and fundamentally we then focus
on providing that customer with an
amazing customer experience you know
we're a responsible lender that that
pays a lot of attention to to you know
managing the risk but also making sure
that that customer you know the funds
are dispersed quickly and and uh you
know we look after that customer and
what's the sort of typical duration of a
loan the average is about 50 months um
so you know these are typically life
purchases uh typically you know people
buying a new car home improvements you
mentioned debt consolidation you know we
think that responsible debt
consolidation is a really you know
positive thing for consumers you know if
you have some credit card debt that's
built up you know to pay that down on a
lower interest rate is obviously a
sensible decision I'm amazed given how
often the the personal finance Pages
have written about this that there's
anyone who thinks boring order credit
card's a good idea well you know
ultimately life events do occur and
sometimes they're a surprise you know
someone's boiler might break down and
they've got to replace their boiler it's
about paying that credit off as quickly
as possible that is is that the sensible
uh you know way for that customer to
handle that so we don't necessarily
think that credit cards or or any form
of lending is bad it's about how you use
it responsibly and that's where the
lenders also have a duty to make sure
you know as fluoro does that we we
encourage our customers to be
responsible and given what you've just
heard from the chancellor there would
you anticipate seeing loan demand
increasing in the latter half of this
year it's certainly possible you know
what we're hearing from both government
and uh from from the bank of England is
that they are going to you know get
inflation under control and ultimately
you know that is necessary but what in
turn that's going to mean is higher
interest rates in the market we saw
yesterday that Nationwide increase some
of their their borrowing costs for
mortgages by up to 0.45 you know that's
material when you think only a couple of
years ago the whole mortgage might only
cost 1.5 percent so we're seeing big
increases on a day-to-day basis which is
unfortunately impact households all
right gotta leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you
stubborn inflation doesn't seem to have
been putting off Shoppers with retail
sales coming in stronger than expected
last month
the office for National statistics says
sales volumes grew by half of one
percent month on month in April
economists had predicted a rise of a
third of one percent well that compares
with sales volumes in March which fell
by even more than expected are first
reported by 1.2 percent but volumes were
down by three percent compared with the
same month last year although inflation
meant Shoppers spent more well joining
me now to talk about this is rule on
Prince who's the chief commercial
officer at the payments platform and
yeah nerulon good to see you this
morning is this really a bounce back
from a rain affected March do you feel
thanks for having me Ian good morning
yeah I think it's um yeah the weather
has clearly impacted shopping Behavior
this month I think
and obviously there was a big increase
10.1 percent in a lot of state benefits
that were paid at welfare benefits
pensions last month do you think that's
probably driven demand to an extent as
well
if there's more spendable income people
will will definitely use that yeah
so where do you think we go from here
then in terms of uh retail spending I
mean the bank of England said last week
that uh only a third of uh the interest
rates thus far the last 17 months have
uh hit home and impacted uh Shoppers is
there going to be a shock do retail
sales fall off a cliff at some point in
the future
um let's see I think we've been spending
a lot of time at out there and doing
research we've done a big research of
the past period and we're seeing that
consumers are very much looking for
deals so consumers are very focused on
finding discounts finding deals so it is
really in the heads of people and it
will show in behavior and I think
retailers need to really yeah prepare
for that and act on that I mean
obviously you're a global business what
are you seeing across the rest of Europe
right now I mean we learned yesterday
for example that Germany has gone into
recession a lot of that appears to be uh
weakness in household spending
I think you know we're seeing the same
Trend across Europe
um consumers are very focused around
um yeah spending looking for discounts
whereas on the other side our research
again consistently across Europe shows
that retailers that have been spending
and investing in technology to support
their customers better across the
different sales channels online in-app
or in store they see a bigger impact in
their sales so there's a bit of a dual
message for retailers deal with
discounts people look for discounts but
at the same time if you're investing in
supporting your customers better that
will pay off on the long term so how do
you deal with that
yes you're talking about something here
called a unified Commerce system what
has the uptake been like across Europe
in this regard
um slower than you would hope I think a
lot of retailers struggle with older
technology
um you know we've seen that
um there's still lots of retailers that
want to do much more
um and unified Commerce what is it it's
about supporting customers really the
way they want to be supported whether
they interact with you online or in a
store or no mobile that's what unified
Commerce is about regardless of the
channel give them the support the
service they're looking for and it's not
easy because you need to bring
technology in-house to really make that
possible
I'm probably being slightly unfair by
asking you this but if you had to
generalize which segments of the retail
sector have been better at doing this or
is it just down to individual companies
nah it's it's definitely individual
companies that do really well I think
companies like Uniqlo Nike they have
really focused around what is real true
ways to use technology to make shopping
more effortless more seamless
self-checkout but also thinking about
different consumers have different ways
they want to interact with you make that
possible not a one-way Street really
diversify per customer segmentation so
to say everybody has different needs
what about the role of consumers
themselves in this is this a change in
Behavior that's almost being driven by
consumer demands
it's very much driven by consumer
demands I would say
um you know our research showed that 61
so two-thirds of people they make it
very clear that if they're able to you
know for example buy something online
with a retailer bring it back in store
they're going to be more loyal to that
brand so it's simple things like this
make it easy for them to interact with
you and they will become more loyal and
they all claim they will okay Roland do
we have to leave it there good to talk
to you this morning thank you
thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and the former chairman of Tesco and
Barrett developments has said he may Sue
The Guardian newspaper for its reporting
of allegations about his personal
conduct John Allen has stepped down from
both positions during the last week amid
concerns that the allegations which came
from Anonymous sources and which he
vehemently denies were causing a
distraction to both businesses well Mr
Allen a former president of the CBI told
the times I'm determined as far as I
possibly can to prove my innocence
the drugs giant AstraZeneca said this
morning that a combination of two of its
Blockbuster Cancer drugs had shown
positive results in Trials when they
were used to treat recurrent endometrial
cancer AZ said that using infinzy a
treatment for lung and bladder cancer in
combination with limpaza a treatment for
ovarian cancer had demonstrated a
statistically significant and clinically
meaningful Improvement for patients
endometrial cancer is the sixth most
common cancer in women worldwide more
than 417 000 patients were diagnosed
with the condition in 2020 while more
than 97 000 women died from it that year
a whistleblower whose tip-off helped the
U.S Securities and Exchange Commission
bring a successful bribery case against
the Swedish telecoms equipment maker
Ericsson has reportedly received a
record 279 million dollar reward the SEC
which pays whistleblowers Awards of
between 10 and 30 percent of fines it
collects in civil enforcement actions
where it collects more than one million
dollars revealed the payment earlier
this month but it did not say which case
it was connected to but the Wall Street
Journal is reporting that the payout
relates to the 1.1 billion dollar
settlement that the SEC reached with the
Swedish company in 2019.
I'm the chief executive of open AI the
company behind the generative artificial
intelligence chatbot chat GPT insisted
this morning he had no plans to leave
Europe or some Altman was speaking amid
signs of growing differences between the
US and the EU over how to regulate AI
technology the European Parliament moved
earlier this month to expand its
proposed AI act to take in so-called
large language models like open ai's
gpt4 and Mr Altman earned indicated
earlier in the week that this might lead
to the company ceasing to operate in
Europe well in a tweet this morning Mr
Altman appeared to play that down he
said we are excited to continue to
operate here and of course have no plans
to leave
now Richie sunac is due to meet Sundar
pichai the Google chief executive in the
latest of a series of conversations he's
had with tech industry Executives well
on Wednesday he met Chief Executives of
chat GPT firm open AI Google and deep
Google deepmind and anthra poik in which
they discussed the potential risks posed
by artificial intelligence and the need
to regulate it but is regulation even
possible well joining me now is an
anther Seeker the artificial
intelligence lead at totter consultancy
services and Arthur welcome to you is it
even possible to regulate AI I'm in the
European Parliament seems to think it is
absolutely it is possible and it must be
done also if you really look at it we
have had challenging Technologies before
be it cloning be it genomics gene
splicing or autonomous vehicles we have
found how to implement guard rails on
them to put bounce on what can be done
what can be done so absolutely it is
possible to regulate and be sure but
what does this regulation look like I
mean there is a sort of perception that
a lot of this stuff is kind of Black Box
stuff that's difficult to get into uh
yes there is some black box Ai and there
is a white box AI we think that a lot of
the AI that will be adapted by the
Enterprises will actually be white box
AI you take a decision using and it's
supported by an a tool on on a mortgage
application or something you have to be
able to explain back to them so we call
it explainable AI so that's what white
box air means so you have to be able to
justify what sources what data you use
to train the model so you are able to
show demonstrate that the
accountabilities with the company to
demonstrate that there is no bias that
you are taking a fair decision positive
human rights etcetera Etc so the
responsible AI is absolutely a big part
of how this has to happen on top of it
there's a level of transparency that has
to come in through regulation we can
insist on certain level of transparency
that has to happen so that the public or
aware like you are doing in your shows
and once a public or aware then there
can be a debate in the society
in terms of what is the right balance
between Innovation and regulation Rishi
sunak after his meeting uh with those
industry leaders the other day said it
was important to demonstrate to society
the benefits of AI absolutely are you
surprised that he even has to make that
point though there's a lot of concern
that is going around around AI people
are not talking enough about what a can
do if you really look at it a huge
transformation is going to happen across
all Industries touching every part of
the business right technology is going
to be a bigger part of every business
process in the world in every industry
how is that who is going to deliver that
Transformations take a lot of people so
we are going to need an army of people
to deliver the change that we have to
achieve right there's a level of
personalization that is now possible in
terms of be product creation Services
Innovation down to ways of working in
terms of how we deliver these services
inclusivity in terms of embracing
everybody people with who are
essentially challenges into so how they
can interact with systems and as well as
the elderly to the young to the people
in remote parts of the world the
opportunities there to absolutely take
knowledge to the front line okay so the
real value of a is there and it is going
to create lot more jobs than it destroys
yeah you're clearly very optimistic
about it why is it do you think that the
conversation about AI seems right now to
be so dominated by concerns about risk
it's natural for anybody to look at it
in terms of how it impacts what's
happening today that it's people in the
industry who have to be talking a lot
more about what's the value creation
opportunity is any analyst your doctor
will tell you that a is an enormous
value creation opportunity probably the
biggest that we have had something that
can help businesses with Top Line and
with bottom line simultaneously okay and
fairly in quick order those are not
opportunities that come to businesses
all that easily there are huge number of
jobs that are that will be right there
is a normal amount of data that we are
assuming has to be processed somebody
has to deal with it so data data
analysis jobs will go through the roof
in terms of explosion of jobs on that
you need detailed knowledge of business
processes data Technologies everything
to be able to work in AI so the the
fears are overblown at this point of
time because people are naturally
focusing on on what worries them but
once they see the value then they will
understand that actually a is a Force
for good for the society I mean the
conversation about AI has really sort of
taken off since the launch of Chachi PT
a company is actually equipped to talk
about it enough I mean you obviously
make a living from providing consultancy
services but I mean if you take the
average Chief technology officer in a
ftse 350 company are they sufficiently
getting to grips with this as a as a
technology some yes some know uh it's
everybody has now become mother that's a
good part of what chat GPT has done GPT
has been around for a while but chat GPT
has put a easy interface on top of it as
an application generative AI is the
technology the potential for generative
AI as a technology is enormous it has
been around for a while everything that
it can do beat in terms of images or in
terms of synthetic data and anything
that can be achieved with generative AI
is fully transformative and there is a
lot of literature now being pushed out
by people thought leadership papers
unless meetings conferences it's it's
the Talk of the Town right now okay so
people are coming up to speed uh but
this is the kind of space where unless
they try it out Hands-On in their own
company through experimentation and
allow their employees across
cross-functional teams to participate in
such experiments so that you get a view
in terms of the people impact the legal
the risk all kinds of views around that
area they won't be able to progress and
write it into Enterprise strategies and
take action for that all right another
we're going to leave it there I'm afraid
good to talk to you this morning thank
you for meeting you
still to come here only in King live
we're going to have a look how Global
markets are doing this Friday morning
don't go away
[Music]
foreign
Spencer and I'm Sky news's arts and
entertainment correspondent as a team
we've interviewed some of the biggest
stars in the world the likes of Tom
Cruise Brad Pitt Sir Elton John we try
to give you an honest sense of how these
people really are
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well last night's mixed finish on Wall
Street in which the NASDAQ Rose by
nearly one and three quarter percent
powered by an astonishing 24 game for
the chipmaker Nvidia was followed by a
largely positive session for equities in
the asia-pacific region overnight as you
can see only the Hang Seng finished in
negative territory in Hong Kong well in
Europe stocks have also been uh mixed
this morning they're all in negative
territory right now in fact uh so things
have uh have switched to the lower side
of things in the last half hour or so
talking points today include the French
Supermarket operator Casino the shares
have fallen by six percent after they
return from suspension today and that is
amid ongoing talks with creditors well
here in London the ftse 100 is also in
negative territory albeit it's only down
around a tenth of one percent right now
some of the mining heavyweights are
protecting it from further Falls there
it's got to be said there are not too
many features for investors to hang
their hats on in the ftse this morning
outside the ftse though Asos the share
says there are off by some three and
third percent right now that is on news
which came out late night after the
market shot last night that it's raising
75 million uh pounds worth of money from
shareholders via a new issue of shares
and the digital consultancy kin and
Carter it Shares are off by some eight
percent that's after it reported a
Slowdown in new sales growth on the
foreign exchange markets well the US
dollar is currently on course for its
third weekly gain as expectations build
of further interest rate rises from the
U.S federal reserve but the pound is up
by nearly a quarter of one percent right
now against the dollar uh the Euro
meanwhile is also slightly head against
the Euro so things have changed around
since I wandered into the studio on that
front as for the oil price well that's
slightly lower this morning
look at that it's unchanged now it's all
changed in the last half hour try and
write these scripts as close as I can to
coming on there but they still catch you
out occasionally as things done the oil
prices on course for only its second
weekly gain in six about a Brent crude
will currently set you back
76.26 about it's more or less unchanged
actually I'm joined Now by Sophie
lundier she's lead Equity Analyst at
Hargreaves lands down Sophie good to see
you this morning let's start with Asos
sir and that this announcement came out
after the market closed last night we I
gather they've got this share issue away
hi good morning yes absolutely so this
was really the the big one from
yesterday and as you say it was after
after the Bell
um so essentially what Asos are trying
to do is Shore up their balance sheet to
the tune of 75 million pounds from three
main shareholders but the very
interesting point from from my
perspective is this five million um
pound retail raise that they're trying
to
um trying to achieve now the main thing
really for me here is that those shares
aren't being offered at a discount
um which should really be taken as a
positive in my opinion no equity raise
is ever a great look to be to be honest
particularly in these circumstances and
but the fact that those shares aren't
being offloaded at a very steep discount
is is significant and does show a mark
of Confidence from management it really
does I mean the fact they got this away
so easily is uh is also quite striking
yes definitely
um it does show a certain level of
underlying strength arguably there's
certainly a lot of conviction there
um you know and I think a lot of that
comes from the fact that there is an
awareness that Asos frankly does have a
strong proposition and a decent brand
um it's being kind of it's being
bruised by external conditions more so
than anything you know including some
really quite crippling wage inflation in
its distribution centers things like
that you know the cost of living crisis
has put it in a really difficult spot on
the margin up front as well not to
mention demand too
um so there's a lot of things going on
outside of its its control
so if you let's stay with retail because
yesterday we had results from pets at
home which really did shoot the lights
out didn't they
it did indeed and pets at home a stock
close to close to my heart I can
certainly uh can certainly resonate with
the with the strong sales performance
there they had record sales of 6.6 and
that's what I'm Keen to talk about it
today because you know we keep hearing
about the cost of living crisis
retailers is a difficult spot and all of
this but actually pets at home is doing
remarkably well
um but what is going to be very
important to monitor from this point is
what happens to margins so we're seeing
that people are spending Less on more
lucrative things like accessories for
their pets but they are still spending
heavily on food because you know cutting
back on feeding and looking after our
pets is going to be one of the last
things that gets trimmed even when times
are difficult
um so what that means though is that
margin accretion you know inflating
margins is quite a difficult
um thing to do at the moment and that's
what I'll be monitoring and for the next
for the next set of results okay uh
Sophie I'm afraid we're gonna leave it
there we're really pushed for time today
but lovely to see us ever thank you
thanks
still to come here on inking live the
Boomin art investment that's led to a
major acquisition don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Ukraine has raised the threat of cyber
attacks on Western businesses and
governments as entities sympathetic to
the Kremlin seek to undermine those
countries supporting Kiev mobile
networks are under particular pressure
with an Israeli newspaper recently
highlighting how they're being
weaponized by Bad actors through the
ability to pinpoint the location of
mobile phones and intercept messages
well the Swedish company anir provides
Telecom security software to some of the
largest Network operators in the world
including Vodafone joining me now is its
president and chief executive Jan
hagelon John welcome to you um are these
threats to mobile entities uh networks
coming more from State back to entities
these days then
thank you Ian it's a it's a pleasure to
be here
um yes yes they are and we see that with
with these threats coming from different
kind of sources can be individuals can
be private companies selling this as a
as a business and in fact criminal gangs
We There are reports saying that that
state actors in fact is growing in
importance and uh I think the Ukraine
war it's it's a fair guess to say that
that is that is fueling activity in this
area and as a security specialist we see
this globally
and all these Russian entities
particularly sophisticated compared with
some of the other state-back entities
that we see in the cyber security space
it's fair to say that the the threats
against the mobile networks are becoming
not only more and more but they're
becoming more advanced also you see that
there are a lot of resources Behind
these uh attacks one of the attacks
angle one of the attack angles is
through the signaling networks where all
the mobile networks are connected to
each other they need to be otherwise we
wouldn't be able to place calls or roam
between different countries but these
signaling networks also provide
vulnerabilities that would then with the
right capabilities allow not only
location tracking but in fact the
interception of calls also and is this a
relatively new weapon in the Armory of
those who would seek to do harm
yes you can see and we've been looking
at specifically the Ukraine war and and
you can see there that mobile networks
are both Targets in the war but they're
in fact also weapons and there have been
reports where location tracking have
been associated with some military
activity we can also see that Ukraine
have done some impressive things where
they have for example blocked the access
to their networks for incoming Russian
subscriptions and phones and people
which in fact then has hampered
Communications quite significantly for
the attacker I think there's a lot of
learnings for other countries on what
the ukrainians have done
is this all translating into extra
orders for you I would assume it would
be
we're listed a company specializing in
products and expertise for for cyber
security and we see a lot of interest in
our Solutions we are often taken for
advice in this area we have a pretty
broad customer base more than 100
operators across the world and we have
new business yes so um yeah so we're
happy about how that is developing
we talk a lot about Artificial
Intelligence on this program uh just now
to what extent to Bad actors
incorporating that into what they're
trying to to do with Networks
are the threats against mobile networks
are becoming more and more advanced and
artificial intelligence allows you to to
have to Stage more advanced attacks also
on a global scale but artificial
intelligence is also used on the defense
side and we have Solutions whereby we
can use artificial intelligence to to
counter also the unknown we can see
patterns and by using artificial
intelligence quickly adapt and create
countermeasures
separately and what are the other
developments in the sector that are
exciting you right now I mean I see for
example Microsoft is talking about uh
taking its Azure Cloud operating system
into uh telecoms what's the implications
of that for you
and you can say that telecoms are
becoming large I.T systems and therefore
not surprisingly Cloud technology is the
basis of all telecommunications and
Microsoft is among the players that have
taken significant steps into
telecommunications networks for us as a
software company this is good because we
specialize only in software applications
our software runs on on any Cloud so I
think the evolution here will bring a
lot of benefit it's going to bring
agility speed Innovation and also in
fact operational efficiency
all right yeah and we have to leave it
there good to talk to you this morning
thank you
thank you so much
[Music]
time for look at this morning's business
pages and the financial times is
currently leading its Digital Editions
with news at the U.S President Joe Biden
and the Republican house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy have moved closer to a two-year
deal to limit government spending and
averse a U.S debt default the Ft
splashes its print edition meanwhile
with the report that the government is
considering reforming the pension
protection fund that's the Lifeboat
scheme which protects people with a
defined benefit pension when their
employer becomes insolvent the Ft says
that proposals being considered by the
treasury would see the ppf's remit
widened so it has a more active role in
taking on Company pension plans that
have not failed well that story also
makes the lead in the business pages of
the Daily Telegraph which reports that
the Tony Blair Institute will recommend
next week that sponsors of the smallest
four and a half thousand DB schemes
should be allowed the option of
transferring to the ppf as part of its
coverage the telegraph also has an
interview with Andrew Griffith in which
the city Minister says pension schemes
need to take a greater degree of risk
with their Investments meanwhile the
times leads its business pages with news
that the U.S drugs giant Eli Lilly has
suspended a potential investment in
Britain because of what it describes as
the country's stifling commercial
environment its comments come amid
industry unhappiness at a 3.3 billion
pound NHS sales levy on branded
medicines the times also reports on last
night's unexpected 75 million pound
fundraising by the online fashion
retailer Asos well join him in hours
ever on a Friday morning is Neil Collins
the financial markets commentator and
evening standard columnist Neil good
morning to you the big Market story of
the week has been this uh spike in guilt
yields you've got some fairly uh
interesting observations on this
well
um we thought after the excitement of
trussonomics which drove yields on
government securities to uh 20-year
highs uh we were going to have a more a
quieter time after that and uh yields
indeed came down to not much more than
three and a half percent but in the last
few weeks uh they've started well
they've gone up a long way and they're
almost now back to the levels that they
were at the height of that particular
excitement
this matters because uh if the
government has to pay more for its new
debt then obviously it has much less to
spend on anything else and at the moment
the government is trying to well last
month it borrowed 25 billion pounds new
borrowing uh to try and bridge the gap
between income and expenditure and that
money has to be paid for and obviously
the more the higher the cost of that the
less there is to spend on anything else
now you could ask yourself why this is
happening and I think the things really
spooked the markets right are the
inflation figures which we had a couple
of days ago not so much the headline
rate which showed a very small drop but
the so-called underlying rate which
actually Rose and this is the thing
which makes people most nervous and it
looks as though uh the the fight to get
in inflation out of the system is really
going to be much longer than many people
thought and that is why the the bias of
uh have Departed the um the guilts
market and oddly enough uh AJ Bell the
um the the
money manager
um reported that its clients are now
buying guilts so the individuals seem to
have sensed that there's something to be
as value to be had here even if the
professionals are all saying there isn't
um which is quite an interesting
contrast but it is this is quite serious
you know this level of Interest the
amount that the government's got to pay
is if it stays at this level then it's
going to be extremely difficult to
finance the government's spending even
at the current rate let alone the
project projections in the future which
is pretty terrifying I mean that
ultimately then means to either rises in
taxes or Cuts in public spending
well
um Jeremy Hunt uh promised to do the do
the Hard Road when he became Chancellor
and in one way he did by raising
taxation fairly High watering level but
we seem to be in a position where we
have the highest level of Taxation since
the second world war and we also have an
eye-watering deficit between what the
taxation brings in and what the
government spends which is quite an
impressive rather Grim achievement to
have done both at the same time
what a damn beat note on which to uh
Neil always good to see you this morning
thank you pleasure
now more than a decade of near zero
interest rates has raised the profile of
investing in art especially among High
net worth individuals that's not only
created a boom in art it's also created
one in the often complex business of
packing transporting and shipping Fine
Arts and antiques around the world or
one of the fastest growing players in
the field is the French company
convellio which has just acquired the
london-based Fine Arts services provider
connoisseur International Fine Art well
joining me now to talk about this is the
managing director and co-founder of
convelio eduard Eduardo good to see you
this morning what a tragedy to this
business
well my my co-founder and I um
historically were working for tech
companies and then we moved into into
the Fine Art industry about seven years
back
um when and that's at that time that we
realized that to actually transport a
piece of art it was a significant budget
and to get a shipping quality would take
essentially anywhere between 48 hours
and five days and and the geographical
coverage was relatively limited so we
thought that actually creating a
One-Stop shop from which someone can get
instant shipping rates that are
competitive and with a larger graphical
score points the way forward and so
that's that's why we decided to build um
six years ago now
why is it a specialized business why is
it something that's a normal logistics
company couldn't handle
well there are there are many elements
right like the first one is whatever
we're being we transport are unique
right and so so the level of quality and
of details you need to put into picking
up an artwork packing it um creating its
managing the Customs uh booking the
right type of freight and so on and so
on is something that's highly specific
um highly specialized and and so that's
not that let's say you you cannot move a
a million dollar like a million pound
painting the same way you would you
would send a pair of sneakers obviously
so there are a lot of expertise that
goes into each one of these steps and
and that's one of the reason also why we
did the acquisition of afghanista in the
UK
how do you charge your fees what's the
basis for it do you uh is it a function
of the uh value of the item being
transported
no really so the only elements that's
linked to the value of the artwork is
essentially the insurance right but
otherwise the way your price is
calculated is a set of budgets that
corresponds to each step of the
transport so typically the first step
will be
picking up an artwork at the gallery or
an auction house and then there's a
certain costs packing packing it as a
certain cost as well um booking the
Freighters at certain cars doing White
Cloud delivery as another and so we kind
of combined all of these different
budgets um from our own operations but
also from external companies that we
work with and we take your margin on top
and how uh how expensive is the
insurance
well it will depend on the price of the
artwork but um it essentially is between
0.3 and 0.8 percent
and did you have a UK presence before
this acquisition
we did um as a matter of fact we had
before the acquisition of connoisseur we
had a team of a bit more than 35 people
um based in London so now that brings
the size of the team to a bit more than
50 people in the UK
what are the uh big trends that you're
seeing now in terms of the art that
you're transporting what's hot right now
well it's I mean we we don't really
follow Trends as potency I mean like
there are there are some some let's say
yeah I mean there are some trends that
we seriously but like it's more linked
to to what we see at auctions um right
so it's typically like right now we have
a lot of contemporary cells and that
we're transporting at the moment but in
general I would say that the overarching
trends that we're seeing is more as to
the way the art marketers are always
moving and and that is moving towards
more digitization
um primarily as as collectors are
younger and younger and obviously expect
a different kind of experience whenever
they're purchasing out right so we see
more Trends again on on our business as
a whole rather than actually kind of on
the outmarket per se which is something
we don't really really track
if we've been sitting here a year ago
we'd have probably been talking about
nfts I mean were you quite worried at
the popularity of NSE nfts and how they
the threat they pose to physical art and
antiques
actually I think it's quite crazy like I
see the other way around but I think
it's super exciting to see that we're
actually starting to bring digital art
like it's a whole new category which is
bringing younger collectors to the
markets and which then in turn are
typically tend to to collect physical
artworks as well so it's bringing a lot
more new collectors and is growing the
size of the Art Market in a way which
we've never seen before so I see that a
lot more than opportunities and actually
uh a threat
all right it's good to uh hear that uh
Edward it's really been fascinating
talking to you today thanks for joining
me
thank you
still to come here only in King live how
a r and a I are coming together to help
people with hearing loss hear everything
around them don't go away
[Music]
thank you
I'm Katie Spencer and I'm Sky news's
arts and entertainment correspondent as
a team we've interviewed some of the
biggest stars in the world the likes of
Tom Cruise Brad Pitt Sir Elton John we
try to give you an honest sense of how
these people really are
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
thank you
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back we have some breaking news
to bring you now on the legal action
that's being brought by families who say
that the hormone pregnancy test primidos
cause severe birth defects our home
editor Jason Farrell has been on top of
this story right from the start he's
broken many angles on it he joins me now
live from the Department of Health Jason
what's the latest
well the news is that the claimants have
had their claims struck out uh by Mrs
Justice Yip who was considering this
there was an application by the
manufacturers and by the government to
strike out this claim in other words to
say that it doesn't it's not viable it
has no realistic chance of success in
the courts and therefore they shouldn't
have the cost of going to court to
defend it and the judge has agreed with
them in this case uh saying I conclude
that the position has not materially
changed in the claimant's favor since
the trial that they tried to take back
in 1982 all those years ago it says it
would be manifestly unfair for the
defendants to require them to incur
further substantial costs in defending
this action further it's not in the
interest of the claimants to maintain
their litigation in circumstances where
there's no viable plan to progress the
claims are no real Prospect of success
and I think that is referring to the
fact that they didn't have the funding
they didn't have the legal clout to take
this to court that was a lot of the
argument in the case that they simply
hadn't got their funds in place and
therefore this case is going to not go
to court and that will be incredibly
disappointing for more than a hundred
claimants who have tried to get
compensation for what they feel was
damages that were caused to them by this
drug I have to say just standing outside
here at the Department of Health less
than three years ago Matt Hancock then
the Secretary of State for health
apologized for those victims for
failings following a review but the
government has stood alongside the
manufacturers in ensuring that this
claim doesn't get to court
Jason this is going to cause absolute
dismay to the uh families here what sort
of levels of compensation were they
looking for
Jason can you have lost my conversation
sorry about that we seem to have lost a
Json file we will of course have more on
that story throughout the morning here
on Sky News now while concerns are being
raised about the risk posed by AI it's
proving invaluable for some people the
British company x-ray glass has married
AR that's augmented reality with AI to
create smart glasses which provide live
subtitling to help deaf people and those
with hearing loss for the glasses can
easily be mistaken for standard
sunglasses and the latest iteration of
the software x-ray glass can translate
into 76 languages opening up the market
for tourists and business Travelers who
are joining me now is Dan scarf he's
chief executive of X-ray Dan welcome to
you um how long has it taken to develop
this technology
well it was quite a Herculean task that
we had to go through to actually get all
of this to work it's something that
sounds quite trivially simple but when
you actually try and implement it it's
quite the challenge so we've been
beefing away for well over a year now to
bring all of this technology together
and how big is the addressable Market do
you think
well one in 20 of the world's population
have some form of hearing loss when you
actually start to use some of the other
features that perhaps we might talk
about later on in terms of our assistant
actually this is now something which
might be useful to people with a whole
range of neurodiverse conditions so
actually you might take that up to one
in three people when you start to talk
about people who go on holiday or maybe
go to a business meeting abroad you
could almost be talking about anyone on
the entire planet who might want to use
this software
how difficult was it to marry AR with AI
surprisingly difficult uh and in fact it
was it's all about speed certainly with
subtitles because it's you're in a
conversation you want to be able to read
those subtitles in real time so we had
to get that processing delayed down to
under one second so capture that audio
send it up to the cloud get it
transcribed get it back onto the phone
and then up onto the glasses in less
than one second so that was a challenge
audio is a challenge of course making
sure that we've got good quality audio
in order to get good quality
transcriptions but you bring all of
those together and you have a magical
experience the AR Hardware Market in the
UK is is relatively uh nascent I think
that's probably a kind way of putting it
is that going to hamper you with the
commercial roll out
so we don't make the glasses uh we
partnered with a number of the world's
leading AR glasses manufacturers so
these particular glasses for instance
are made by a company called xreel we
also have partnered with TCL we've also
partnered with rocket so for us this is
all about consumers choosing which are
the best glasses for them and then safe
in the knowledge that our software will
be compatible with them and I gather
this is I mean this is very personal for
you you got the idea from a family
member I gather
my granddad who was 96 at the time and
like many 96 year olds had lost almost
all of his hearing and he was just sat
surrounded by his family unable to
engage in the conversation there was
almost an identical story from another
founder Paul our chief product officer
it was his dad rather than his granddad
but by the wonders of the the internet
and Linkedin we came across each other
and we decided to do this business
together we brought a whole bunch of
other folks along as well and we spent
the last year creating this incredible
piece of software and do you think this
is going to have other applications
so I think the assistant is where this
starts to get really interesting so we
spoke about transcription and
translation but we've also wired this
entire application up to chat GPT so I
can say things like hey x-ray can you
summarize this conversation for me
please or hey x-ray I missed the name of
the town that we were just talking about
can you remind me what it was or hey
x-ray what was the thing that I was
supposed to do today um so this ability
to be able to have access to this
real-time assistant the entire time we
think is actually what's going to come
to Define this product
terrific Dan it's a lovely story uh for
us to end the program with today
appreciate you joining me thank you
that's it from me coming up next it's
Sam Washington thanks very much for
joining me today
[Music]